for a generation that is not only
suffering more anxiety than previous
generations but also struggle with
forming deep meaningful relationships
that feeling anxiety may be one of the
single best ways to form the connections
that they so desperately need to manage
the anxiety it's a virtuous circle it's
the wisdom of anxiety and we have
completely cut ourselves off at the
knees from benefiting from it you know
we talk about social media and how
dangerous it is to our youth here's
where I think it's most dangerous it is
cutting off our kids ability to go deep
connect with real community and purpose
which is what you need to leverage
anxiety for you need to actually have a
sense that there's something greater
than yourself so we're actually stopping
kids from Gaining these tools to
actually hitch anxiety and discomfort to
purpose and connection that's what we
have to fix